hey you guys flickers of fear time my
little movie review series and this is
the second installment of
giallo july we're doing all giallo
movies this month uh two every week
this one and the one that i did
previously these are going to be the
only neo gelas i'm talking about um from
this point forward they're all going to
be like old from the classic era of
jealous from the 1970s so hopefully you
guys are looking forward to that but i
did actually kind of want to talk about
this one because
this is one that i had kind of heard a
lot about that came up on a lot of lists
lists of like nealo uh neo giallo movies
and it sounded kind of interesting so uh
so i had to like give it a look if you
recall
in my previous uh review of the 2015 neo
geology movie francesca
i emphasized that though the movie did
actually have a fairly standard murder
mystery type of plot which is you know
common to these types of movies
its main attractions were mainly the
visuals um you know the sound design and
you know to some extent to the
painstaking care that have been taken to
recreate like the exact look and feel of
a gela movie from the era's heyday like
back in the early 1970s
now if that was true of that movie
take that sentiment and multiply it
about a million times
for
today's movie which is the 2013
very abstract uh giallo reconstruction
which is called
the strange color of your body's tears
which is like a classic [ __ ] jealous
title now i will say that as i mentioned
uh previously about a other a lot of
other neo giallos this one is not
attempting to recreate the look you know
like francesca as i mentioned was very
very obviously trying to look like a
lost yellow film from the 1970s like you
know it was meant to look old it was set
back then this one is actually set in
you know what was then the modern day
2013. you wouldn't really know that
other than like a few characters using
like the technology that they're using
and things like that because it's very
insular and it's in like a very old uh
art nouveau type building but um this
isn't like trying to recreate that at
all but
uh all of this stuff applies about this
being a purely visual movie and
don't look for a plot seriously we'll
get we'll get into that so this was made
by uh helene kate i think is how you
pronounce her last name and bruno
forzani now these two are a husband and
wife filmmaking team now they're both
originally from france but they're
actually based out of brussels belgium
and have been for several years now they
made uh they made several films they
made a movie back in 2017 which was like
a weird western uh called let the
corpses tan which i saw like the
beginning of but i haven't like uh
finished watching it yet it looked kind
of interesting uh but more significantly
they also made another neo-giallo called
amer back in 2009. now this was actually
like pretty well received by critics i
haven't seen it yet although it's on my
list
but from everything that i've read about
it
what it is is it's essentially like a
plotless
very experimental film that's more like
a series of vignettes i guess
that is basically just sort of like
utilizing the imagery and the archetypes
of the giallo film the genre in order to
explore kinds of themes of female sexual
experimentation or maturation or
something like that
so uh if you've seen that movie this one
is kind of along those same lines uh so
it's kind of more of the same
but this one
and like i said i haven't seen amer so
i'm not really sure i mean but like i
said they sound kind of similar
this movie strange color was so like
relentlessly surreal
that i would absolutely be lying
if i told you that i had any [ __ ]
clue what was going on in this movie i
really did not but not at all like for
the first
15 20 minutes i was on fairly solid
ground and then after that it just goes
like while i let them just kind of like
okay and then you just gotta like sit
back and just let the visuals wash over
you because it's i'm not to say it
doesn't make any sense i think there's
like something in there but
don't go into this like looking for a
cohesive narrative because i'm pretty
sure there's not one okay so like more
than any other geology movie because you
know how like a lot of people that
aren't super into jealous and it's like
oh like the plots don't make any sense
yeah that's like this this movie is like
the equivalent of somebody saying a
dario argenta movie oh the plot doesn't
make much sense and this movie saying
here hold my beer you know what i mean
it's it's that kind of thing this is
like it is the most
plotless and in the sense that it's not
meant to be plot heavy the plot is not
the point of the exercise this is very
much an experimental film it's very much
an exercise in pure filmmaking not so
much like a narrative thing so okay
picture this
picture if
david lynch's lost highway
and
dario argento's inferno
and
sergio martino's all the colors of the
dark
picture if those three movies were
people and then they had a three-way
in
this sort of blood-soaked attic crawl
space that was painted with alphonse
mucha murals
and then they all somehow collectively
gave birth to a baby that was made
completely out of hallucinogens okay
then you're kind of like part way there
that's how
out there this movie is it's very out
there so uh all that said i would
definitely definitely not
recommend this movie to anyone who
wasn't like a complete giallo junkie
uh and would appreciate it on that on
those terms or uh you know on the other
sense like somebody that's like really
really appreciative of like very very
experimental films and even then i'm not
really sure because i kind of feel like
to get the most out of it like i was
saying about francesca you really have
to be kind of well-versed in like the
tropes of giallo and like the symbolism
and you know the you have to like know a
lot about the visual language to get the
most out of it but if you're just into
like [ __ ] with like crazy like really
beautiful grotesque sort of visuals then
you might dig it too other than that i
don't really think anybody i think this
will probably just be like a beautiful
endurance test like for most people uh
that aren't into that kind of thing but
despite that i actually found it rather
mesmerizing like in a very kind of like
nightmarish what the [ __ ] am i watching
kind of way uh you know the visuals are
like very sumptuous like all the set
design is just like ridiculously
gorgeous and it does have a
kind of like a veneer of like mystery to
it so there's like mysterious [ __ ] going
on so you are just kind of like what the
[ __ ] like is this all going to connect
or what the hell is even going on or
what does it all mean so i did kind of
like get into it that way the only
criticisms i'm going to say some of the
images did get slightly repetitive
because some of them are you know
repeated several times um so i felt like
the run time maybe could have been
knocked down a tad i mean it's not super
long it's an hour and 40 minutes or
something like that but you know just
there was some repetition in there i get
why they were doing it but you know they
probably could have like trimmed it down
some uh but that's really kind of the
only criticism but like i said don't go
into this thinking there's going to be
like a story story because there's kind
of not it's mostly just a series of
visuals it's kind of like a weird like i
don't know like a
dream sequence like a very very long
like dream sequence
where
you feel like there's some kind of like
logic in there somewhere but you can't
really put your finger on what it is
okay i mean it's like overall it's
really like let's call it like a feast
for the senses but absolutely approach
this more as like a piece of visual art
rather than a narrative film and i think
you'll be okay so i'm gonna try and give
something of a synopsis if that word
even means anything in this context uh
but forgive me if it sounds a little bit
disjointed because to be honest i'm not
entirely clear on how all the pieces of
the puzzle of this movie like fit
together or even if they're necessarily
supposed to or if they're like supposed
to mean anything in particular you'll
kind of get the gist as i'm kind of like
describing what's happening in this
movie so we start out with a businessman
named dan who repeats several times that
he's in
telecommunications i'm not sure if
that's significant or not
now he's apparently been on a business
trip to frankfurt so he's returning home
to brussels from frankfurt he's been
there i think like two or three days or
something like that
when he arrives uh back to his apartment
building which is oh my god this
beautiful like art nouveau and i guess
it's like a real building where they
shot it in brussels and it's i want to
live there right now it's like oh my god
it's like [ __ ] gorgeous it's just
like art nouveau like murals all over
the woodwork i was just like
like all the wallpaper i was just like
heaving with kind of like oh my god
oh my god the architecture porn i was
like so into it and like the decor porn
i was like really really i could have
just watched it for that like i didn't
even need any like dialogue or anything
i could have just watched it for all the
like how beautiful it was you know what
i mean so there was that
so he comes home to his apartment
and he discovers that the door is locked
from the inside like it's locked in like
the chain is on
but his wife is nowhere to be found
uh his wife incidentally is named eviege
which is a little bit of an odd little
kind of reference there to uh the
gorgeous edvige finish
who was actually in a bunch of giallo
movies back in the 1970s including
several uh directed by the
aforementioned sergio martino including
all the colors of the dark which i
mentioned earlier she was in a bunch of
his actually but she's kind of like well
known for being uh in a lot of glo
movies uh during that time period so dan
is naturally worried about where his
wife has gotten off to
and becomes even more alarmed when he
sees that the phone messages that he
left like over the few days of his trip
uh he they're still on the answering
machine and they haven't been accessed
like the whole entire time that he was
gone
so he goes around and like rings all the
other tenants of the building you know
it has that to get the thing where you
can like buzz up you know and stuff like
that we don't really have those here in
florida but i know they have those in
europe and like some places up north and
stuff like that but you like buzz up to
people's apartments and they can buzz
you up
so he buzzes around to everybody pretty
much nobody knows they're like who the
[ __ ] is that we don't know what you're
talking about or at least they tell him
that they haven't seen her
but then he buzzes in one to one
particular apartment and a woman's voice
tells him to come up to the seventh
floor like as if she possibly knows
something so when he gets up there to
this woman's apartment she's ostensibly
sitting in the chair like waiting for
him but all that he can see of her
is like her legs from the knees down and
she has like these black witchy boots on
and she has like her hands have she has
like lace black lace gloves on and her
hands are like on the arm you know the
arm chair or the armrest of the chair
and that's all of her you can see like
the rest of it there's just kind of like
a pool of light in the middle of the
room and then there's like where her
upper half and her face and stuff are is
just like impenetrable shadow it's just
like black so he's like trying to peer
in there but you can't really see
anything so she gives him a cup of tea
and she starts to tell him
her
story now it turns out that she doesn't
seem to know exactly where edvige is
but she does say you know my husband
paul
also disappeared not very long ago under
very strange circumstances
so then the movie kind of like goes off
on sort of like a tangent or like a
digression where it's talking about what
happened to her and her husband
so essentially what happened to them is
they're like in their bedroom and they
hear like all these weird noises like up
in the ceiling and i'm not actually sure
if this building has like an attic or if
it's just like the roof up there and
there's like what the [ __ ] why is
somebody up there and they keep hearing
all of these weird noises
so paul goes he's like a doctor and he
has a stethoscope so he goes up there
and he starts like listening around like
to the ceiling and everything like that
and then he drills like a little hole in
there and he's trying to like look up in
there but he can't see anything and then
later somehow he gets up into the crawl
space or the attic or whatever the [ __ ]
is up there uh to see what's going on
like what's making all the noise
so his wife is standing on the bed and
kind of peering through the hole that he
made and she sees paul's eye like on the
thing and he says hey it's like really
dark up here can you like hand me up
some matches so i can like look around
so she does that like she puts matches
up there and paul seems to be like
looking around she can hear like hear
him walking and stuff but then he says
something really weird about the people
in here or the people up here or
something like that this movie is like
in several different languages i think
that there's some i think there's uh
there's french obviously i think some of
it was flemish maybe i think there might
be some i don't know if it was dutch or
danish i don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on in there but it's like several
different uh languages going on because
i think a lot of the actors are from uh
different places so then so she hears
him say that like someone else's eye
appears like peering through the hole
and then there's like a sound like a
shin like a blade you know what i mean
and then like this single drop of blood
like comes down to the hole and like
lands on her face
so she kind of like tells that story
dan um is basically like well what the
[ __ ] does that have to do with like my
wife disappearing which i mean it kind
of does have something to do with maybe
that's what happened to her too but he
doesn't really seem to seem like the
similarity uh so after a bit he ends up
leaving this creepy lady's apartment
having never seen her face like and
she's obviously like getting really
nervous because her teacup is shaking
and she drops and breaks and everything
like that
so he's like okay well [ __ ] this noise
and he goes up to the roof i'm guessing
like to see
what's up there like maybe there's
something up there maybe he's like
checking it out but he goes up to the
roof
and then like standing there just like
casual as you please is this completely
naked brunette woman who's just like
standing there at the edge like looking
out over the city or whatever just like
smoking a cigarette and he's just kind
of like sup you know what i mean they
just like kind of stand there and smoke
together and it's like no one explains
anything and i'm just kind of like all
right this is that kind of movie you can
see it's just there's that now dan does
actually call the cops at some point
but the inspector that shows up to the
apartment is really suspicious of him um
and there's this really weird like
interrogation scene where
his face and the inspector's face
because all the dudes in this and all
the women in this more or less kind of
well more or less look kind of similar
to one another so i think there's like
some kind of like lynchian identity kind
of uh situation going on here but i'm
not entirely sure but so they have like
this interrogation where the inspector
is asking all these questions and then
like they'll intercut like it'll be like
you know dan's like the lower half of
dan's face and then the upper half of
like the inspector's face like split
screen and then there's like quarters
it's crazy this has like all kind of
like crazy like visual like camera
tricks and all kind of like crazy [ __ ]
like that so yeah so the cop is like
suspicious of him especially after he
says oh you know i think my wife might
have been taken or somebody that has
something to do with it like a suspect
is this bearded dude that i saw like
acting kind of suspicious and he went
into the apartment across the hall now
when they get the landlord in there um
the guy that lives in that apartment
doesn't look anything like the bearded
dude and he's like i don't even know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
there's no bearded dude that lives here
never has been and the landlord like
backs him up on that later on dan even
thinks he sees this same bearded dude in
his own apartment for a minute but he
doesn't have any idea like how he might
have got in there or if it's like some
kind of ghost or what the [ __ ] he
doesn't know there's also another kind
of strange digression because it's
almost kind of like he's going to the
different apartments trying to figure
out what happened to his wife but then
like everybody that lives in those
apartments has their own like weird ass
[ __ ] going on and they're kind of like
telling him about it so it goes like
into all these like weird
different stories like of other people's
stories that are all sort of
interconnected like in the kind of way
so this other digression has to do with
this man and i'm not sure if it's the
bearded dude or not like i said they all
kind of look similar so i'm not entirely
sure like who's who so there's a guy and
he's in a dark room and he's taking
pictures of either the same brunette
that was naked up on the roof or just
another brunette that kind of like looks
like her not entirely sure uh the dark
room seems to be
situated right behind this woman's
bedroom i'm thinking because like he can
watch her sleeping and she's naked and
stuff and the photographer can like see
everything she does through like a
one-way glass with pain but i'm not
entirely clear on whether she knows it's
there and like it was put there on
purpose or if somebody else put it there
and that are spying on her i don't
really know uh this particular sequence
uh also involves
this weird woman that's like all in red
like a red leather dress red boots
um like a red hat with like a red veil
over her face like you can't see who she
is like she follows some people around
she kills one [ __ ] she like
meets somebody and they're you know
exchanging some [ __ ] like in this crazy
building with all these columns and
stuff i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on i don't know who that is
uh so
as if this wasn't like incoherent enough
it gets even more out there like from
from that point on and from here on out
i can't really remember
uh in what order some of these events
happened but i don't think it really
matters all that much because like i
said this is not you know a plot point a
to point b to point c it's just very
dream like and so it's just like a kind
of a series of images which all kind of
seem interconnected in some way but i
don't think i even saw like another
review of this where they said well
probably you could rearrange all the
scenes in any order you wanted it it
wouldn't make any difference and i think
that's probably the case um maybe there
was a couple things that you'd have to
put at the beginning to like you know
establish it but after that it really
doesn't seem to matter like all bets are
off i mean for instance there's one
sequence which like i said was was very
david lynchian or i kind of perceived it
that way like dan gets woken up by his
doorbell buzzing like in the middle of
the night it looks like
and then he goes and looks out at the
security camera but it looks like
he's standing out there like wanting to
be let in even though he's inside you
know i mean like it's his doppelganger
or something this scene is actually like
repeated several times with slight
variations and like slightly different
outcomes like each time
one or more of the versions seems to
imply that one version of dan killed
another version of dan so like i said i
think there's like some identity or some
kind of not i don't know if i want to
say possession necessarily but it could
be that it could be like shading over
into that uh at one point too and like i
said there's i'm gonna i was gonna say
spoiler alert but really like i said the
plot isn't
really the main thing about this or even
a thing so it doesn't really the concept
of spoilers like really doesn't apply in
the situation
but at one point in the movie dan seems
to find
edvija that's his wife like her severed
head like lying in bed next to him one
morning like he wakes up and he sees her
and he's like oh it's her oh [ __ ] it's
just like her head or whatever
and he does mention this to the police
but the head is never found and it's not
mentioned again after that so
i don't know
uh dan also with the help of the bearded
man from earlier who he initially
thought was a suspect like the dude
talks to him through the wall very dario
argento's inferno that's like for real
what it reminded me of but i'm sure
that's what they were homaging um so
with the help of that guy
he discovers that the entire building is
like catacombed with
hidden passages like behind all the
walls
and that's how people can get into and
out of all the apartments without being
seen in the hallways that's how the
bearded guy like turned up in his
apartment and stuff like that so people
can like go around behind the walls and
like look in other people's apartments
like through the stained glass and all
this other kind of stuff there's also
this hole which seems to be the whole
like crux of the mystery i guess
uh is this strange woman named laura
who's also like a brunette woman now
apparently this woman used to live in
the building and was really into kind of
like sadistic or like transgressive like
sexual practices like as a way to i
don't know if she's trying to like
get out of her body or something like
that or like access some other worldly
other interdimensional i'm not entirely
sure like what that was doing but people
in the building who remember her
they all insist well you know it can't
be her she'd be an old woman now so
apparently they're saying like that's a
long time ago but there is apparently
like some version of her that's still
lurking around evidently um
in the guise of this ever-changing like
brunette woman who may or may not be the
same person or who knows yeah so there's
like all these brunette women kind of
like lurking around um you know there's
pictures like photographs of like
different brunette women who kind of all
look similar
now it's speculated at one point and i
can't remember which character said this
but
um that dan's wife edvige
got involved with laura's experiments in
sexual sadism like she went up to the
seventh floor or whatever like that
apartment and got into it because she
was bored with dan or she didn't like
dan anymore she wanted to destroy him or
something like that and maybe she went
up there and got involved with that and
then she got killed like because of it
um you know whether during the thing or
somebody killed her because she knew too
much or something like that
it's also barely possible i suppose
that dan was actually laura the whole
time
and the entire film is kind of a long
hallucinatory nightmare sequence in
which he finally comes to terms with
this fact and that maybe he killed his
wife himself but
i mean i could be totally talking out of
my ass there that might totally not be
what's going on but that was one
possibility that did occur to me later
there's this bizarre and yet still quite
beautiful sequence shot entirely in
black and white and it's filmed in this
really kind of like herky-jerky almost
like a series of stills you know what i
mean like kind of put together
um and this takes place after the
landlord finds what is presumably like
laura's diary like she's talking about
why she does certain things
i mean and during this sequence there's
like a hat box or like a set of hat
boxes there's one hat box which is like
black and white striped um has a hat in
it but then sometimes
it doesn't have a hat in it and then at
one point like a dude in a hat like
comes out of the hat box very babadook
and it comes out of the hat box and then
he's just like this shadow dude and he's
like chasing this woman and then at one
point they're both like underneath the
wallpaper and it's like bulging like
while he's like pursuing her like under
the wallpaper then he like pursues her
like through this big hole in the wall
like through this tunnel and [ __ ] like
that it almost looks like animation but
it's photographs yeah it's like it's
super super weird
there are also a whole bunch of like
recurring images of
uh black and white scenes of like nude
women having like knives pressed against
their throats or things like that uh one
oft repeated image of kind of like a
straight razor being brushed over a
woman's like erect nipple so there's
there's a lot of nudity in this too so
you know just know that going in a bunch
of people get stabbed in the tops of
their heads like with big like blades
and stuff and the stab wounds on all of
those people look very obviously like
vaginas
um you have a lot of like extreme
close-ups of eyeballs
at one point it looks like a person
climbs into or out of another person a
woman is like fed a single pearl while
she's sleeping and like coughs it up
later this is not explained there's kind
of one kind of cool scene where there's
like all this kind of plastic hanging
and there's like a body up in the thing
but there's all this blood like kind of
speckled all over the plastic and it
looks just like a bunch of rubies it's
like really cool looking there's kind of
like one scene where dan like goes to
this woman who i presume is laura and
like takes her
robe off so she's like naked but then
she starts like glowing like a [ __ ]
supernova or some [ __ ] like that it's
it's crazy i mean it's all very
like i said grotesque and it's very
impressionistic
and i mean the images are very
provocative
but they only really seem to make sense
in the context of like a dream logic
kind of way and i think that that was
kind of the entire objective of the
movie this is more like a movie of
sensation and feeling not really of like
analysis i guess you know so while there
is a story thread in there about dan and
his missing wife and kind of how maybe
she had had these forays into sort of
like sexual extremes of like the
sadistic torture and maybe madness uh
and also the fact that maybe all these
other people in the building there's all
this weird voyeuristic [ __ ] with all
these people like creeping around behind
the walls and like watching other people
and maybe they all knew laura too and it
was all kind of something to do with
that so there is kind of like a story
thread in that sense
but i think the whole intention of the
movie
was more to sort of use this iconic
symbolism and all of these like visual
hallmarks of the you know of the classic
of the giallo genre to sort of make this
multi-layered
kind of
visual dismantling of the essence of the
genre i guess is what they were trying
to do while they're also maybe possibly
i could be totally wrong about this but
um maybe
telling a sort of like obtuse story
about you know just the allure of like
peeking into other people's intimate
lives and maybe sort of like the dangers
of exploring the far limits of sexual
power dynamics something like that
or
you know as another possibility it could
have been something maybe more akin
to this
hilariously dismissive
and uh but not entirely inaccurate but i
did like this movie so i thought this
but this did make me laugh uh so this is
a review that was in the guardian
and they had a very impatient one star
review of this movie
and they opened it by comparing this
movie to quote a feature-length advert
for a perfume that would smell like
tuberose leather and rotting meat with
top notes of fake blood and old cheese
and i was kind of like
it's a little reductive but it's not
untrue i mean you know what i mean this
does play very much like
a feature length there is dialogue but
much like francesca there's not a huge
amount of dialogue and there's a lot of
sequences with just
score and visuals so this would actually
play very well
you don't well i'm not going to say you
don't need the dialogue i mean you do
kind of but to otherwise you could be
completely at sea and not know what was
going on
but
i mean if you just wanted to like watch
this like a visual experience you don't
really need to know what's going on
because even if you listen to all the
dialogue closely you probably won't
figure it out anyway and i don't really
think that that was the point of the
movie
so you know so i'm just saying that so
like i said if you're not super into
giallo movies um i'm and you're not
super into like arty movies then stay
far away from this one because it will
probably just like try your [ __ ]
patience like within the first few
minutes i mean maybe not the first few
minutes because it does it's not
coherent like from the jump but at least
it does seem to kind of have like a
narrative thing like at the beginning
but then it just goes off into this
phantasmagoria of like all of these kind
of giallo esque images that seem
interconnected somehow but you're not
entirely sure how they are so like i
said it's just kind of like a very dream
logic nightmarish kind of movie but that
said um if you know that going into it
it is actually like really really
beautiful to look at in like pretty much
every scene of it is just like some kind
of like cool [ __ ] going on so whether
you want to like watch on you know an
hour and 40 minutes of that is entirely
up to you but you know i quite enjoyed
it uh you know i'm i'm more like the
murder mystery aspects of you know
giallo of old but i actually really do
respect this as you know just like a
piece of art even if not as a narrative
film so that will do it for this
flickers of fear our second installment
on giallo july and we'll be doing
another one on the next one so i will
see you guys then
bye